the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
11 rounds weren't enough at the u.s
chess championships in saint louis now
it's time for a playoff wesley so sam
sevion and fabiano carawana occupy the
top spot on a crowded podium looking to
knock off their rivals and claim the
title for themselves three gladiators
are prepared to battle for glory and the
title of the u.s chess champion the
climactic culmination of the 2021 u.s
championships coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to st
louis for the finale of the 2021 u.s
championship well we've already crowned
a champion in carissa yip in the women's
division but in the open we've got to
take care of business as fabiano caruana
wesley so and sam sevillan will go at it
and try to etch their name in
championship lore to call all the
exciting action we're going to jump to
the studio with christian and yasser
the majestic gateway arch overlooking
the vibrant city of saint louis host of
the 2021 us chess championship and u.s
women's chess championship from the
studio at the saint louis chess club i
am your host grandmaster christian
carrillo and i'm joined by my brilliant
co-host grand master yasser sarawan
yasser this is it the finale absolutely
christian it's been a wonderful
uh event and it's been great calling the
action with you and maurice
absolutely hello everyone and welcome to
our live coverage of the 2021 u.s
championships it's playoffs time we had
a very very nervy
championship round 11 but let's take a
look at our standings after those 11
rounds christian do the honors start
with the ladies we're going to start
with the ladies indeed well we had one
dominant champion that is carissa yip
who just stormed through the event
dominated the field and took home the
cavity title as well as 25 thousand
dollars very nice and what happened of
course there she is what a beautiful
smile absolutely
a riveting championship they're really
the latest indeed and what happened in
the open in the open well things are a
little bit more murky we have fun piano
caruana wesley so and sam savion heading
into today's playoffs and what are those
tie bricks there they are tight at the
top that's juan faviano caruana one
wesley so and one sam sevian the
newcomer to the playoff scenario exactly
and what is the playoff scenario well we
have three players tied for first so we
are going to play a rapid round robin
the game is going to be in 10 minutes
with a two second delay we don't have
increment anymore right now we're
playing with delay if after that first
rapid round robin two players are still
going to be tied then they're going to
be playing a two-game blitz mini match
gaming three plus two seconds delay if
three players are still tied then they
will move on to a blitz round rubbing
gaming three plus two second delay and
what happens if two players are tied
after all of that well that's uh when
madness ensues on the board because we
get the armageddon white is getting five
minutes black is getting four minutes
and black also gets the draws
no increment no delay is going to be
wild absolutely and last night there was
a drawing of lots performed by the
arbiters
to determine today's pairings let's
listen in on how they did it from last
night so chris will you draw for
grandmaster samuel sebian first
and what number at the bottom
number one
and then you draw for grandmaster wesley
so
three
that means that the last pawn better
have number two
for grand master
fabiano caruana number two
okay for the drop lots it is uh samuel
sebian number one
caruana number two what is saw number
three
and that takes us to
this scenario in round number one sam
savion is going to take a rest carwana
is going to be facing wesley so caruana
with the white pieces then in round
number two sam savion who comes well
rested and is facing fabiano caruana and
then in round number three wesley so
will be facing sam sevilla so our two
favorites face off in round one oh
that's exciting but maurice ashley is in
studio to tell us the line scores of the
players and how they got here maurice
it's been a pleasure calling all the
action with you
great to see you for the playoffs thanks
yaz it has been incredible the drama in
this tournament has been so intense
indeed and now we get three separate
players we've got two superstars in the
world of chess in faviano caruana and
wesley so and then the upstart in sam
sevilla just amazing who will win one
player going after his third title the
defending champ right now wesley so
another and fobby going after a second
and sam sevillan trying to upset the
apple card and get his first speaking of
sam let's take a look at his line score
he started out with a win in round three
but then had what seemed to be a
devastating loss in round five but much
like a champ he came back in rounds six
and seven and got two wins and then
coasted the rest of the way to be now in
a tie for first wesley so speaking of
coasting
wesley one in round two and seven but
that was it a bunch of draws a couple of
missed opportunities for him he was
quite dejected and not being able to
seal the deal in the first phase of the
event now he's got his hands full
against two hungry monsters who want to
take the title and we want to talk about
a monster this player the world number
two
he looked dead in the coffin pour on the
grave the the dirt and walk away crying
except no he had a new story to write
after round six
minus one turn into a win and even then
a draw and then two wins in rounds nine
and ten
find him tied atop the leaderboard with
a chance will he be able to show
just what kind of gladiator he truly is
fabiano caruana would write an epic
story if he won
but that's why we play the games we'll
see in a minute who is going to be the
champion remarkable comeback to be sure
maurice and let's go up to tony for the
start of today's playoffs
and welcome to the playing hall on the
playoff day of the 2021 u.s chess
championships i'm tony rich uh i will be
joined here with the chief arbiter frank
guadalupe and all three of our players
sam savion fabiano carjuana and wesley
so they'll compete in a round robin
format rapid time control event time
controls game in 10 minutes with a two
second delay
at the end of the round robin if we
produce a clear winner he will be named
our u.s champion if not we repeat the
same procedure at a faster time control
we go with game in three minutes with a
two second delay so it'll be a blitz
time control if necessary and finally if
we have to we go down to armageddon
games to determine the champion so as
the arbiters are preparing the clocks
and getting the playing hall set as the
players are arriving we'll begin the
round in just a moment back to you guys
thank you tony thank you tony
and uh yes sir you were wondering what
yes he is as well but as we see the
players a little nervy affair there uh
wesley and fabi getting ready for these
playoffs but they're smiling there's
a nervous smile a nervous smile as uh
sam as you said sits out there's genie
sinc field
a little fist bump uh there's that nerd
yeah and
we've seen the increment throughout this
entire
event they get the 30-second bonus
take our viewers again what's the delay
so delay is very different
whenever you play with increment you win
extra time every time you make a move
with delay you don't win anything you
cannot gain any time so the way it works
once your opponent presses the clock
your delay starts running so in this
case we have a two second delay okay one
two and now your clock starts uh running
so always and throughout this entire
playoffs the clocks will be ticking down
they will never jump up they'll take
down but they won't start immediately to
tick down yes there will be a delay
and when these two players face off
against each other look at that score
holy and this is rapid chest this is
rapid chest that's why you wow so many
games because these players have been
playing so
many times against each other
six games all right
you could write up
maurice i can't imagine how many stories
are in that one but the edge goes to
wesley he has been a better rapid player
than fabiano
over the years no question about it
this time though he does have the black
pieces and this is
and this is sam waiting nervously
to see what will be the results well i
think he's crossing his fingers draw
boy right draw he doesn't need them
putting up a number a cert player wins
now it will tell sam that that's a full
point someone has and he's going to have
to win as well more likely than not he
could still somehow do it with with no
he can't yeah he could somehow still do
it with two drawers
but he he doesn't want to have to be in
that situation so a win now is huge and
who has the edge
as fabi plays two games back to back
wesley plays one now
and at the end and sam gets the last two
who would you guys rather be in terms
right because then that gives his
opponents a lot of extra information and
that is the genius right there then
again ring bell we might have a short
day bobby wins this game wins the next
game we're done that's it nobody can
catch him we don't play the last game
yeah so here we go
and this 10-minute game in progress ooh
the botvinnik english to start out this
was something i used back in the day
uh ronald simpson my late friend
showed me exactly this opening
and
here we go
yeah i love to play the english myself
although i didn't play this particular
line i love the
queen side expansion and both players
playing pretty quickly in fact the delay
if you look at it
has meant that fabi hasn't used any time
at all nope he's played all of his moves
within that first two seconds as he's as
this clock remains frozen
at 10.
bishop e3 was very interesting without
the rook on e1 so when you recapture you
have to recapture with the f1 changing
completely the pawn structure yeah but
at the same time that pawn on e3 that
double pawn on e3 does and we see right
there prevent any knight on c6 to jump
into d4
and very quickly
uh
wesley brought his passive knight i want
to say this knight on e7 pardon me the
knight on c6 two e7 into g6 and you
might be wondering what that ring is
that wesley is using to play to fidget
with that is the u.s chess champion i
was about to say isn't that the the u.s
championship it is yeah it was really
pity i mean uh they came out with these
gold rings
uh for the first time in seattle in
2000.
and
ever since they've
they've given them
given them to the champions but i could
have four
i should have four
d2 now big moment for fabiano where will
he focus his plan i coincide with a4a5
and try to gain as much space as
possible or
d4 and try to play in the center i think
he plays in the center i think the move
rook e8 just to just to tap down any
ambitions of white playing the move d3
d4 and i think from wesley's point of
view
he wants to play for his central blade
c6 d5 playing on the king side with
something crazy like h5 h4
trying to gain space over there in my
view makes no sense rookie 8 is a
novelty we've been told
uh that that move is new it does
suppress the d4 push and now rook
leaving a5 by the way is a move that
black can consider white will probably
just advance past it with beat up by the
way there it is a5 has been played and i
think you'll see b5 that's right most
logical way to play on that side but
that does allow for a hook with the move
c6 that has been played and black is
certainly intending to go for d5 as you
mentioned yes
white center coming quickly under
pressure
could we see the actual shot because i'm
not 100 that we that those were the
moves that were played those were the
moves that were played 100 percent they
were basic you meant you mean the the
view of the board the bird's eye view
yes i don't know it was definitely that
those were the moves and bishop d
man i i feel like ronald simpson is
somewhere
channeling he's smiling these moves
these moves because this just feels
right up my old school alley days in
brooklyn and that bishop now coming to a
new diagonal it could also pursue the c2
square as well so that the d4 push can
be made without any worries but that
bishop is very flexible
where it is actually yeah oh the release
of the the file already d4 becomes a
possibility and wesley with a
temporizing move 8-6 i think he played
h6 was played indeed and now we expect
bishop to a4 try to create some tension
on the pawn on c6 whenever you play the
move bishop to d7 to defend now i'm
primed to open up the d-file and put
more pressure on d6
and the bishop i'm very curious as to
where this bishop goes because it has so
many squares four straight no he's right
away he's going straight with d4 right
away
look at this pawn formation guys by
white i'm not that impressed with the
move h7h6 i thought
wesley just that that move ago
it was now
now was the time break out in the center
with c6
department d65 but h7h6 gave white
opportunity to execute what he wanted to
do which was
now it's very confusing if you put your
queen in front of your rook
why did we use the tempo to play rookie
8 we know that the move rookie 8 is a
novelty but
um
queen looks very strange
to my eyes on the c7 square and i liked
a moment ago we were talking about the
move bishop a3 bishop a4
the problem though that i see with this
position for white is how to improve it
like what are your next few moves
one of the problems with this structure
is that it can become brittle you have
the space but that pawn on e3 stands in
your way and you don't get another break
you get the d4 push but you don't get to
make another break like f4 push for
example and so you're sitting on this
position and black says okay you've got
all that space
very solid see bishop c2 but what do you
do to improve the position where you
can't trade on e5 that number gives you
nothing take it on c6 gives you nothing
maybe a c5 break would be nice but that
doesn't seem like it leads anywhere so
wesley now playing bishop d7 he's saying
your position you've got the space i'm
going to put a rook on d8 and then i'm
going to drop my bishop back and we
might just be staring at each other
because what are you supposed to do with
the white pieces white is going to try
to play something along the lines of h3
i think h3 queen to f2 this is the plan
i'm seeing at least and then what
and try to put some pressure on the f5 i
would love to get the knight to f5
exactly i don't maybe knight to e2
knight to g3 knight to f5 but i have to
be very good see all that so when i play
knight
he's played much more concretely with d5
oh i don't like this move one day i did
not expect them i do not like i don't
like that move uh and what do we see
right now that's scene five square that
is weakened but that's
not captured yes absolutely i i tell you
that that was a tricky position to play
and you had to be patient christian what
you said was very important that
patience may have been the right measure
there as
d5 does not feel right and he's weaker
to see five square permanently and he's
gonna have to fight for squares now as
he can't dominate the position as he was
anymore wesley actually has an open file
and a key square on c5 to work with yeah
in my view definitely a mistake by fabi
he should have played a4 bishop d3 king
g1
knight g1 92 knight g3 knight f5 and
brought the knight to f5 just keeping
all the tension
uh unfortunately for him he's going to
discover that when this rook slides over
to c8 the bishop slides back to e8 and
this knight starts this c5 square is
very tender
that's a committal move that means that
says to me
that wesley is intending to redirect his
queen to the a5 square otherwise why put
the pawn on a4 or wherever that's like
four honorable in fact
but he could also maybe play queen to d8
to b6
is target is bobby planting b6 himself
which seems quite odd but
very good maybe maybe maybe concrete
gain some space over there the thing is
that black's pieces the whole battle now
is on the queen side clear right that's
just clean everybody's going to be
fighting for those squares and maybe you
need to to get another hook on that side
as queen d8 has been played b6 is is
very committal no question about it but
it gains some space you could have put
work on b1 another rook on c1 and say to
say to black
what do you do to really do anything
clear the problem b6 is that i'm going
to be able to redirect my knight with
tempo because i want to get the c5
square after b6 i'm going to also have a
target on route to that c5 square i'm
going to play bishop to e8 followed by
knight to d7 potentially that's why
we're playing rook by six so the
problem i see with b6 as i go after b6
works c5
and after you play rook b1 and we do
have a move queen to b4 and i'm
expecting queen a5 by wesley
queen a5 queen a5 and we see a trade of
queens
rook take queen oh that happened very
quickly like they didn't even need the
delay now i mean from
fabi's point of view he better be really
really fast
in terms of getting his knight to c4
otherwise black is going to take over
the game very quickly black is going to
push his bishop back to d7 is knight to
f and we've spoken about this already
but that said that said about being very
fast and i don't c4 it looks very very
good it's awesome
right now i mean 92 knight c4 that's
good that starts threats it hits
weaknesses it even prepares knight b2
yep let's get cracking and that's
exactly what is that i don't think
that's what he did he didn't see him he
played knight
what a move
so
natural
i'm shocked by this last move is he
added to well he still has a c6 but guys
what's happening right now after knight
to g4
knight to g4 is a question
give me the pawn and he played it knight
right now you cannot keep control of the
c file you have to take on c8 and go
rook to e1 to defend that pawn but that
allows black to go rook c5 take over the
initiative black is to be preferred
right now oh big time well he does have
h3 chasing the knight back no after the
the whole purpose of the knight sorte to
the g
four square was just to win the c file
if you have to what i'm saying rook
takes rook takes rook takes quick takes
and then rookie one rookie one if you
play rook c5 i play h3 and then i'll go
back united states and now if i play
rook c1
and broke through e1 is on the board and
knight to
e7 and we've got rook e1 on the board by
the way a big question right now for
wesley so is if he can take on c1 yes
and if fabiano takes back
with the rook can you take the pawn on
e3 or is it that that's good
that's dangerous
great defense by fabi there rook takes
so he there's no domination on the c
following
i think 97
97 king
was king
and he can play h3 at any time he can
also start with knight
d2 again what's wrong with knight d2
both players down their last five
minutes his knight is not doing anything
at all on f3 why doesn't he want to move
it i don't know it's it's so strange
for me which is also very strange was
fabi brought his knight to a2
possibly to b4
and onwards to c6 i think he was
fighting for the c file yes
now i saw it in ic6 but not as a real
threat are you serious i mean you post
your knight on c6 and then what if i
don't take it for example exactly but
now you don't have any support on c1 so
what if i just trade the rooks and then
go rook to c8
challenge the rook on the c file and you
cannot capture on c8 and exchange the
rules now be careful because you could
lose your a pawn
but your opponent e3 is yeah you get the
e3 and they get the a pawn and then he
has two passers i mean he has two
against one on the queen side by the way
that's something to calculate at least
h3 was played okay here's here's the
moment
nope
any rip takes and knight takes he didn't
want to do it he didn't finally tonight
is going to see finally but that b-pawn
is going to hang when you play knight c4
so he's got to time that properly as
well
your king is not only eight because if
the king is on e8 then i can take on d6
afterwards right
the king moves by wesley
miss timed yeah there you go he missed
time he mistimed it all right yeah he
lost
this knight should actually be in the
game but guys he's a c8 what if i
actually go knight to c4 right now
and bishop takes b5 and knight to b6 i
take the rook i take back
and i have to defend
to a5 and then you've got to give me
seven i
that looks worth it he's looking at it
right now they're down to four minutes
and 35 seconds for wesley 357 for fabi
so fabi
he's got a great chance here knight c4
looks excellent looks at least dynamic
with you know why because the two
knights on the king side are not in play
they're stuck they're over there for now
and you have a full concentration of
pieces on the other side he's definitely
analyzing knight to c4 to see if it's
worth it how else does he improve on
that side so knight to c4 one more time
if i take on b5 i go knight to b6 knight
to b6
i take on c1 you take c1
i take on d3 you can take on d3 and now
the question is whether yes so you lose
your b bond though i get two you get two
pawns and maybe the third but then i get
the b pawn and then i think i'm going to
get the a pawn as well it's going to be
a
that's what he was looking at you saw
him go deep into the tank that must have
been what he played
on the board that he knew that was the
move i'm sure wesley knew that was the
move as well
and that was a 90-second think in a ten
minute i think that's a big thing
no question no increment no increment
you're never getting that time back
three minutes for fabiano four minutes
and 15 seconds for wesley
completely different ideas rook c5
knight b6 rook a5 the idea is you can't
well you are welcome to take the rook on
c5 but after
d takes c5 so
right now winning
whoa
will he go for it that
i mean intuitively it doesn't look like
it should be playable but the tactics
may favor
knight season
critical
what a move if that works at sheer
genius poetry
it's just it's just unstoppable
knight c6 is fantastic matter of fact
i just went just threw some moves into
the engine and this position could
easily arise with the move d6 check king
takes knight c4 check picking off that
rook on a5 that's the winning money
combination nice e6 right now
a brilliancy he's calculating it no
question about it that move has been
hovering in the air for some time it
actually works right now if he doesn't
play it i think he is forced to play it
because that pawn on b5 that's the thing
and he's going
there it is wow okay he thought
that it was important to include
the move rook takes c5 did he make the
right decision he did he's just
amazingly beautiful combination with
knight to c6 and wesley so now with a
lot of extra time on the clock but the
position says that he has lost those
knights again on the king side sitting
there out of the battle while
everything the party is on the queen
side of the ball i really thought that
that uh tempo lost king e8 king e7 was
crucial because this knight in in
particular is not as you say maurice in
the scrum um where do i put the rook
because i'm a little bit afraid that d6
check in some variation is going to cost
me but if i put the rook back here
then i'm then there's a potential fork
on that's the problem on c8 i don't have
a precisely the problem you actually
don't have a lot of useful moves right
maybe my best move is c5 c4 to give or
f8 trying to be back with one of the
knights but c4 right now yeah yes
allowing d6
exactly that's the type of thing i'm
saying i've got to force the action
and i can take night check
i can
take you on oh my goodness
i lose an exchange but at least i get a
bond
for my efforts this and wesley's got
really into a tank
wesley has one trump in this position
and that is his time advantage it's
rapidly participating
yeah you you could have as much time as
you want when you're playing fabiana
caron and he'll figure out how to beat
you okay and again those knights are out
of play he needs to figure out some some
way organizing his forces to bring the
knights back
can he play bishop takes c6 dc takes c6
king back
to d8 i don't buy it i don't buy it
because it's it's again it's definitely
it feels like this should be away but it
feels like you're hanging on by a thread
at that point uh suggestions
do what you don't ask us well okay i
made a suggestion and you shot me down
without you
he played it i mean come on you might
make a suggestion and you say you can't
do it
you guys have been that to me from the
beginning of the show
it's on the board guys
it was yesterday you're right it was the
best chance though
oh
knight to d5 knight to d5 after king d8
king d8 is on the board right yes knight
to d5 knight takes d5 knight to e7 he's
going for a dark square blockade
after e
four
he wants to play king to c7 rook back
and somehow get his king brilliant oh
he's doing it in a completely different
way he's putting his knight on d6 right
away i thought
he had oh but this way he has c5 c4 i
think the position is completely turned
fob
he missed earlier a rook b-1 move and
now it is turned around and a blockade
is firmly in place
with the knight on
on d6 c4 let's go
this could be
one of the biggest turnarounds because
we've got rook b5 in the position too as
well as knight b5 f5 is also a move at
that point
f5 isn't right because if rook takes d5
you're absolutely right
you have to defend that pawn on e4 with
the king i really would like to play
he's going through seven first but he
didn't do it on the board he played f5
first your move
nice
nice nicely spotted so what if you go
king to e3 right now
king to e3 i'm really worried that one
of these days i'm just gonna go after
your a3 pawn 35 seconds left for fabi he
knew he had a great position and he has
blown it and now what he's got to figure
out how to not lose as he's never
getting extra time on the clock time is
down 23 seconds and he is
he's frozen wow you've got to get
influenced but he's finally playing e3
and king c7 stopping
v8
what is he supposed to do with the white
pieces
with the white pieces
almost instant elimination exactly and
c3 that was the big money move right
there
because again
he's threatening he's threatening rook
takes d5 guys you have to make four
seconds three two one he's gotta make a
move and he's got one second for the
rest of the game he's gotta play
instantly narrow or lose on time
oh my goodness and
what a turn dramatic where did he miss
his chance maurice it was a dramatic
well let's just first look at whether or
not
that's a huge win forcing fabian to a
must-win game on the next game and that
even that's not enough for his destiny
because if he wins he's got to hope
wesley loses the last game that was such
a massive turnaround
in that game encroaching with the white
people with the white house i don't see
it
i don't see it
i mean like you said at the start there
maurice i think sam was saying draw
please yes you guys just make a draw so
that when it's my turn to play you know
i i'm not under the pressure of having
to win over to your board maurice where
did that moment
was it knight d5
well by the way we should note sam is
now forced to win one game precisely
sam cannot draw two games so that could
open up the possibility of fabiano
caruana taking advantage of that need of
sam savion to win this game and
potentially win a game himself well
it may not be this well this game if he
decides that he has to win with white
against fabi he needs to win that gives
that that opens the door he doesn't need
to win with white he has two chances to
win
of course the odds of winning with white
in the next game no no with black with
black i mean
winning with black in the next game are
much lower but he doesn't absolutely
need to win let's just make that clear
if he draws now
and wins the next game he is
the winner so he's got two chances win
against fabi or dragon and win against
fabi and then he's fine against wesley
draws fine or draw with fabi and beat
wesley and he's the champion so he's got
two options in his mind you've got to
think he wants to win with the white
pieces though right you that's what you
would think but he does not have to win
i think this is almost a must-win
situation for him
because wesley stowe is with the white
pieces but you're saying wants to make a
draw but you're saying you're saying
from a practical point of view it's a
musketeer but from a technical point of
view it is not technical yes let's just
be clear from a technical point of view
it's not but from a practical point of
view you're right you don't want to draw
and then have to face wesley with black
trying to draw trying to win the game
and here is our preparings for round two
while fabiano caruana fell under the
sharp sword of wesley so sharp and fast
because wesley was fast and furious in
this game
wesley played quickly but he definitely
had a lost position
and i think the problem
for for for fabi is he just kind of
sled slept drifted his way into a
blockade position he missed when he
played the move king d-8 he missed the
opportunity
i think to play rook b1 right here yep
that was the move
that was the moment this was the
critical moment right here fabby played
the move knight d5 and wesley somehow
beautifully managed to blockade
everything and the tie turned but if he
had started with
with the initial
move rook b1 then it's wholly different
this knight on g6 is not getting back
into play he's got the threat of knight
c4 and in this case king c7 knight to d5
and after king takes
rook to b6 check
white
is the one with the much better
wow so
when he
oh and for fabulous you couldn't think
of a of of a worse way of starting these
playoffs losing with white i think that
almost
kills it it's it's almost instant
elimination for him technically is still
he's still in mathematically
mathematically still within the realm of
uh winning this championship but
practically it's really really wow
incredible
moment
just so bad for for him the worst start
he could possibly have to lose the to
lose that position a draw and there's
all to play for
to lose
that great position he had as you
mentioned yes rook b1 and get a position
like this would have been oh just so
majestic as a start but we've seen fabi
falter
in rapid and blitz it's not exactly his
total specialty there
unfortunately but look at sam's focus he
knows
this is a big game it's easier for him
to win
this game and then compete with wesley
by the way a draw against wesley
means that he and wesley if he wins this
game a draw against wesley means that he
and wesley go to another playoffs
let's be clear if he beats fabi now and
he draws wesley in the next game
then wesley and sam will be tied at one
and a half and we'll still be here
watching even more playoff action
and while we
take a moment to uh let the players
reset their minds yes yeah the the their
mindset uh commercial sponsor with the q
boutique hi christian
holiday season is coming and you need to
get your gifts ready and we do have at
qubootstl.com this beautiful us chess
championship 2021 usc championship
t-shirts polos we have hoodies
all sorts of merchandise and i feel like
we've gone through an enormous amount of
the catalog that is available at q
boutique because we pulled out some
chess sets and chess boards and all
kinds of different apparel during the
whole so do make an effort to go on site
and do your and we also have a promo
code champs 21 to get uh
20
off of everything well for wesley this
couldn't have been a better start he now
gets a break
and to think to himself oh my goodness
you guys go ahead and make a draw and
then i'm going to draw with white again
there will be no draw fabi will be
resigning
uh if
other than other than drawing like
there's no way bobby's going to allow a
draw on this chessboard think of the
clothes
fabi was to winning this whole thing
yesterday
oh my god painful oh
some kind of justice in chess uh you
don't win it too bad you gotta go you're
not gonna be the champion he was so
close to winnie yesterday but also he
was so close to winning this game
against wesley so he actually played a
brilliant game after that moment rook to
b1 knight to d5 just spoils everything
because after that practically is not an
easy game with black having that
blockade that knight on d6 is so
powerful like an octopus defending that
entry square on b7
supporting the pawn push on both sides
c4 and f5 and such a difficult night to
play a very big moment there by the way
uh hat tip to wesley i mean he played
really with his back to the wall oh
really really really great once he got
his
once he got his grips on the position he
never let it go and this is where we
stand
so far after one round you know you say
that guys and i feel like
this was carrana's game to win or lose
wesley
got his chance of course and once he
could get his knight in the game i think
you me christian uh any decent
grandmaster say okay we got you now you
did my night get on d6 what did you do
look takes d5 that was such a bad
mistake by fabi that it just it just
made life too easy for wesley and guys i
just also want to say one thing when i i
mean we have been witnessing for 11
rounds really hard-fought chess where
that increment i mean the players are
getting used to moving getting the 30
second bonus but we saw that once the
the clock really really ticked down by
fabian he never
got the time back i see a vienna
he was he was going to lose on time yeah
he was not it was one second trying to
make those moves exactly yeah he was
going to lose plus his position was bad
anyway vienna opened anna with f4
no
billy joel vienna waits for you
nice i don't know that song uh
vienna waits for you
here we go he's playing his where's this
card right now if he doesn't win this
game he's out i think he's happy to see
something a lot off-page absolutely
there's not
any force draw lots of pieces he's also
going to be able to get that bishop
so he created imbalance by capturing the
bishop on c4 so
bobby has a little something to play for
very cagey played there by
fabi as he doesn't just immediately grab
the bishop on c4 he just
waits i'm not sure what the theory is
we're in a very dusty part of the
opening chess library
by the way guys the vienna i'm not sure
when the last time i saw it
uh
on c4
and attacking a pawn i'm not sure i i'm
not that big a fan of the move knight g3
but he's playing for a light square
maybe queen
d3 now
uh going to d3 pawn p3
keeping and i have a kg set up trying to
take advantage of that d6 pawn which is
going to get weakened because black at
some point we'll have to play c6 and
take advantage of the fact that you have
a majority on that side yeah but c6 and
d5 worries me a lot c6 and d5 yes and if
i if i put my bishop on g5 with the
knight on g3 h6
asks a very very pertinent question at
all times
i'm feeling like f5 is a potential break
for black but i don't know how to get my
knight to guard that square i'd like to
have a night guarding it but it doesn't
seem
possible the d5 break i'm not a major
fan of the old knight g
98 knight to g7 rerouting and reroute
beat three on the board b2 b3 to my mind
spells the intent at least of playing
bishop e3 i want to rob my opponent of
his trumps in this case the trumps for
black are the two bishops so rather than
playing b3 with the idea of playing
bishop b2 i believe sam is playing b
three five what i don't know how
unrelated to the position because that's
more see how i don't understand what
this moves about how that connects with
the previous play he doesn't secure the
bishop on
c5 in any way
there may be but it wasn't like white's
intent ever was to play a3 and b4 okay
maybe fabi's just
ready to meet bishop e3 with knight d7
i do believe that a5 is aimed against
knight way four i think white was trying
to get that bishop that dark square
bishop with knight to a4
makes sense
makes sense in that way
at least and just take some some space
advantage on that side he's not feeling
like the pawn on a5 is a liability at
least not right now i think with the 97
maneuver you mentioned yes this makes a
lot of sense well to trying to secure
the c5 square but there it is
you both made points there the a5 move
to save the bishop and the knight coming
back to d7 but i think f5 is the move
that black will have to aim for later
but i don't see how to make it work i'm
doing it right now i'm playing knight f5
he played knight to d5 if i'm not
mistaken knight to b5
okay uh that's the wrong direction
surprise direction you're stopping c6
but uh
why is my knight good on b i thought 95
if i couldn't go back for just a second
i thought the intent was to play knight
f5 with the idea that if you do take i
get the very juicy
central outpost e4 for my knight but he
went a completely different direction
with knight b5 big surprise for me
bishop take c3 queen takes c3 knight to
c5 is on the board okay
and
here now there's one thing i notice in
the the knight on c5 has greener
pastures also on f4
if he could possibly get it to e6
so that is something that fabi will be
considering the problem
i see on the queen side actually that
knight on b5 does keep your queen stuck
so right now we've seen rook d1 you
might need to play something like queen
e7
and
and again it's not easy to
unfurl right that knight on b5 is saying
to you check out your your pawn on c7
somebody has to guard that for a while
and if your knight leaves there's going
to be a c5 break as well so it's not
much
but but there's another thing too
remember about this game
bobby has to win
so
so sam knows he doesn't have to do much
to provoke fabi fabi will be provoked in
time
and we'll have to one day
go for something in this place let's go
for f5
that's what he has to do and he doesn't
do it he quickly squeezes b7 queen d7 oh
basics b7 b6 that stops the c5 push
later that i was talking about any break
with c5 by white because the pawn is now
guarding the c5 square in case the
knight leaves and that pressure on the
default but sooner or later he's gonna
have to play for f5 like a queen e7 and
something on that side i don't see
exactly how he executes it though both
players down to their last seven minutes
seven minutes and 45
for fabiano caruana seven minutes and 14
and counting for samsung just a reminder
to everybody this is delay delay
there's no increments it's a two second
delay
shutting down that side completely four
stopping any a5 a4 ideas step one king
h7 is he going for g6 and f5 maybe f5
directly
i feel like
i feel like g6 and
f5 to create more imbalance in the
position creates a lot of imbalance
also the move f4 though is a move for
white once your pawn hits f5 it is
indeed right so that's something it's
like both of them are looking at this
this move f5 or f4 wait a minute do i
want to do it do you want to do it you
do it
no no no i want you to i want you to do
it first
uh so bobby would love to see f4 happen
so he can take and win the e5 square
uh for
a piece i i like this move as a prelude
in case of f5 and you take and you play
bishop takes normally speaking uh you
would immediately capture on g3
with the knight on g3 pardon me the
bishop on f5 but with bond defended it
does give you the option of
keeping that trade and playing f4
immediately so i like this move rook d2
d7 very cagey play by far he's headed to
the f4 square 96 knight to f4 that
knight
had that path line for it and he can
head to the f4 square if he wants to
again he's avoiding any kind of f5 push
and
what did we see happen here queen g5 and
fighting a trade of queens the knight
draw back to c3 that was important
because the queen couldn't leave right
right it was the e
pardon me the c7 pawn that was
constantly on tap but he has to believe
has a better end game though
by doing this because if this is just
equal
he's in trouble no it's he knows it's an
equal length but why would you trade
queens why is black off the play along
just a bit because he was probably
afraid that after knight d5
white may favorably uh create a
situation where f4 could come in here in
case of a trade of queens he feels like
he's playing for two results you can't
get in the move f4 and black can get in
the move f5 also because sam savion
needs a win as well no sam does not need
a win technically not bobby needs a win
fabi needs a win it's a game of chicken
right now
fabi has to win sam can draw this and
say okay now i have to win the next game
good luck he's okay good luck is fine
the kid if you're going to win the
championship you got to beat one of
these two guys it's either him or the
next guy if you're going to win the
championship you've got to do it and you
know pick him you want fabi or wesley
for the win you go right ahead but
it's fabi who absolutely cannot draw the
moment he draws he leaves the building
he's gone he doesn't wait around it's
bye bye fabi you can walk away because
he's out of the competition i think
after the move queen g5 i would probably
just play knight d5
myself so in case of the trait of queens
i could recapture with the knight and
just keep that position with the knight
also going back to d5 well sam is
burning a lot of time on this decision
right now i mean down to his last four
minutes and 30 seconds last two minutes
he's been pondering his decision will he
exchange the queens or
not queen 21 and flinch
no i think it's between rookie one and
knight d5 i don't think it's going to
trade but
i don't i i i think this is a
is not a critical moment this is not the
critical moment to be be burning two
minutes and he's making
a mismanagement of his time by doing so
i think 95 and just play that quickly
because i think the key moments are
still
ahead aren't they five on the board i
don't like that decision ooh
once again he could have started with
knight d5 this bomb on h this h6 pawn
going to g5
really means that you're stuffed yeah
you're not playing f4
okay i'm totally appreciating my knight
through f4
but let me ask you how does fabi
defend the c7 pawn with the royal c8 and
if i attack it
he did not
uh
rook to b8
and if the knight comes back to b7
okay so then your rook would be on b7
all
right
but uh
for from um
um i want to say white's point of view
uh i think what sam was thinking is i
can post my night up on the d5 square
and you can't play the move c6 because
i'll take the spawn
so
sam is thinking that
maybe somewhere down the line you're
simply going to have to take that knight
and i'll recapture and it will be a draw
but okay
if i'm fabby it's all about
g6 king g7 and f5 by the way
oh the other night the other one has
posted on f5 right now
is that a future move
looks good to me i don't know i don't
think you want to take that
g6 g6
97
he's tied the rook down to this pawn on
c7
and remember fabi has to win this is
what sam at least has that card in his
pocket fabi cannot play any variation
that repeats by the way a move has been
played and is it g6 no no no no no no he
has to take the knight to not allow
but now yeah so you were saying
straighten out the pawns with seven six
d5 exactly and how does fobby win this
by the way
knight
9796
is going to is going to be on tap as
well how does fabi win this game he's
got to play for f5 there's no other
players there's no other break that he's
even reasonable right
yeah you don't play for c6 that's just
suicide but g6 what happens after g6
guys whoa what's the what's the pregnant
pause about right now he's spending a
long time about taking with the rook
that's what i'm saying and he did
he took the rook that was a a surprise
encounter
okay
so once again it's about g6 right
you got to kick the knight back
the key for fabi right now
is let this game last as long as
possible no you don't need to be very
specific in your play but he did he went
for f5 and he's going for the aggressive
play he's got three and a half minutes
three minutes and 15 second lead on the
clock to me you need to get sam under a
minute
you should be playing slowly enough you
don't have to force anything don't let
him trade anything off and force him to
panic
and make a mistake now it's time to play
a little bit on the clock without any
specifics king g6 just chill put a rook
on f7 if you need to
force sam to to drive the action as his
time is ticking down he's never going to
get time back
exactly
he's three minutes down
on the clock and counting
whoa
a straight
big move
securing the f5 square for his night
don't like it i really really really
don't like it and he didn't go for it no
you just gave uh fabi a huge opportunity
to play for e
four
and one if you can if you can get in
that pawn break e5 e4
and trade off the f3 pawn the resulting
pawn structure is going to be a
protected pass pawn on f4
the position is starting to look very
processed
and also by the way
why create an h3 pawn weakness
opponent might nibble on that one too by
the way this is the best result for for
wesley this is the best result you could
ask for for wesley that fabby wins that
fabie wins in all cases because
sam will have to win and then we have a
three-way tie and then maximum is a
three-way tie if it's a draw
in the game wesley walks home right this
is the best result because
if there was a draw in this game
then
then if a win by sam and then wesley has
to play some more if there's a win in
this game again a win by sam and he wins
the championship so he wants sam to go
down that happens he knows all he has to
do is make a draw and it's over he plays
no more chess with the white pieces
yes with the white pieces
that's right wesley will have white and
he knows this is the best result
possible all the man says please beat
the kid because he knows a draw does the
job and now it's on fabi to find the
best moves to even state to have his
life saved because if he only draws he's
going home
exactly
wow
and he's got 411 on the clock a good
position
i think he needs to move
back whoa knight back to d7 did not see
that coming the 97 i thought the knight
f6 or maybe
c6 and then tried to land on d4 well but
because he was gonna say you couldn't
have one
that was what i was saying it's
unexpected yeah
knight to b5
i think you put the knight back on c5
and and
he's right right right bobby you should
be gaining time on the clock right now
just repeat whoa he absolutely wanted
his knight on f6
so he could play for e4 but knight d5 is
threatened right knight d5
you can't put the knight back on d7
no and that was just like d7 has to be
played king to f7 this allows 1995 and
what do you do which forces the trade of
the knights i think uh sam decided that
he would like to trade knights but he'd
like to trade knights from the e4 square
i was wrong
all right he guarded c7 with his king
is that progress for him
whoa is that king marching into wise
position
no i can't believe it but again i know
we're going to have to as far as i was
concerned i thought
knight
e4 for white
was the way to go trade that night off
play c3
queen side is locked up king's side is
locked up
center's locked up bobby's looking for a
way to win i don't understand why he
didn't at least gain some time in the
clock because now he's he he had a
three-minute lead and his king is up the
board he looked at sam is playing
instantly the last few moves have been
instant and fabi's time is just
being fritted away but the question here
is can i
say the double-edged
king
b4 you can you can indeed okay i'm
tickling the knight you would probably
have to play rook d3
rook d3 or knight
knight to d5 allows a trade and then
king to c3 that looks good
this allows knight d5 he had to assess
both
d5 he has to assess and again knight to
e4 feels like the move that needs to be
played or knight to d5
i absolutely think rook to wow
allowing him here's e4 whoa there will
be a check at the end of all the
business is a check on d5 so it's think
massive trades on the e4 you don't want
to follow by rook d5 check rook takes g5
so
you got to prep it with c6 king to b4 is
a move as well c6 is a move as well make
a move no no c6 c6 let's go c6 d5
e4
okay this is this is fabi's strategy to
get the pawn to e4 but he i like
i mean he's maximized everything he he
can't possibly
do more than he's done right now but now
the position is getting double edged you
can go for e4 but that's going to allow
white
to grab a pawn but black's king is i
mean white's king does look a little
funny in e4
e4 and taking on f3 is a chance and he's
sitting there thinking only now 20
seconds uh on the clock big decision
right now
e4 now we're never gonna be now e4 now
or never and he's done laura is on the
board whoa rook d6 is allowing the
capture on f3
i'm expecting king f2
black has the better king in the end
game by the way
of course that king on c by the way rook
to e2 is that a move rook to e2 followed
by knight to e4
take the rook but then you take the pawn
on f3 no that's not enough no no
knight takes pawn takes pawn takes two
and that finishes should be the killer
that finishes the game that's the key
move
what is he thinking about right
now
check rook at six doesn't work just
that is a win for fabiano caruana what
he's going to take on e2 he just needs
to take on e2 and that's game what is he
thinking about what is he missing he's
thinking of rookie two i can't believe
that no come on pawn takes
doesn't take with the pawn
he makes that move no there's everything
why does that have an image it's a
response it's resigns there's no move
it's it it's over it's over both works
are hanging 94 check is one pawn takes
rook is the other
he's got to resign in this moment now
after this game sam savion will be
forced to win in order to
create a three-way
that's right
but he had to beat one of the big dogs
you you had to do it you you want it to
be fabi okay now you see what happened
now it's time to beat wesley but it was
very strange he played queen g5 and it
seemed to mean like he was playing for a
draw
sam savion was playing for a draw
thereafter this is not going to do it 94
check is enough are we waiting for two
results with white i don't get that
yeah right a lot
that was not necessary i don't get that
and now we're expecting with it
with an extra piece this will be child's
play
rook e3 94 check would be
my
approach
uh
king to c5 christian love that move
i like i like your move knight
94 check let's go anything wins yeah i
think so too that's the knight of c3 or
king to c5 that's it and fabian a must
win game has
done it and now has forced sam
with the black pieces to have to try to
beat wesley so tall order tall order
wow
that would be
short of a miracle
for some savior to win with the black
pieces against wesley so yeah there was
something we've seen miracles in this
event including wesley almost never
loses you remember that grand chester in
paris yes
rapid and blitz he did not lose a single
game up until round 16 or something like
that right he's not a guy you try to
beat hey guys
he never loses uh it's been a black day
but black
is playoffs it's been a black day black
is okay
black is okay not only okay black is
sweet
two wins for black so far i i think uh i
think it's time to review
[Music]
our predictions as to who was going to
win the open
what do you think yeah yeah yeah
anyway
anyway
let's read it
yes refresh refresh well all our viewers
memories all i can say you had a good
chance for him
excuse me you still have a decent chat
where are we
you should be quiet
he was a halfway point you're not you're
not even i'm out anymore you're not even
in the discussion as a jeffrey between
me and yasser down to the wire it went
all the way down to the wire if yasuo
gets this one then kudos to you yes sir
good pick mine of course was also a good
pick and the other uh appealing gallery
participation participation trophy
congratulations to
by the way producer please make sure we
understand that this was not the only
pick that was made in this event there
is the pick for the women's championship
as well ornament
championship
tournament drum roll
and there we go ancient
the women's champion so if we had to see
who did the best combined picks
i also won that one
i was with arena look
one two and three that's not that bad
that's not bad i mean we are we are
you participating
not bad not bad now we're talking about
how on earth you're
you're
sam's coach
how
what do you say how do you prepare sam
for this all-important
adult yes
[Laughter]
those who don't know this story this is
brilliant this is a brilliant story you
got to tell it quick though oh gotta
tell it quick two
great players from argentina grew up
together
played
in all of these argentina
championships miguel quinteros and
sergio rubinetti truly they were
brothers in arms and they were playing
in a tournament in buenos aires with the
great bobby fischer
at noon
miguel receives a knock on the door and
there's his brother sergio
and he says miguel
you have to help me you must prepare me
for my game with bobby fisher
and what does brother miguel say to his
best friend forever for life he says
listen there is absolutely nothing i can
do for you in the next two hours that
it's going to change your destiny you're
going to lose
let's go out and have a lunch and after
the game you could tell me how close you
are to making a draw
which is precisely what happened but
hold on just a second you're you now
come on you gotta yeah and help me out
on uh setting up the game
you gotta help sam savion come on get
give him some advice give him some good
advice
to
beating the great wesley so
listen
there's nothing you can do
let's go and have a lunch
let everybody go
all right seriously though if i did have
to give him advice my biggest advice yes
is don't
play for a quick win that's not going to
work don't play crazy sharp openings
that's not going to work
play slowly and make the game last the
way fabi just did against you play
slowly but surely but slowly but surely
and let the game last 50 move 60 moves
you're going to have to somehow outplay
him you're not going to catch him in
some opening prep
nobody's catching him
that's not gonna happen
you need to lengthen this game as much
as possible and you need to stay ahead
on the clock since he's getting no
increments you've got to be faster and
then when he makes an error which is
everybody makes a mistake
you need to be alert for all those moves
and pounce but you're not winning
quickly well with good chance
that's good general advice how how do
you do it i played one e4 exactly
i'm not sure if he will button
no then i'm playing an open sicilian why
not c6
i'm not going to know about it
is a great way to play for a win why not
a modern why not uh why not uh what
carissa did a hippopotamus again a very
very decent way of keeping the the
position fluid lots of pieces on the
board but that's what i was thinking was
looking for was the specific advice
maybe the modern would work against d4
as well i think yes
there's a lot of ways to force the draw
with white
the modern is the only one i don't even
think of anything e4 d6 d4 g6 yep
fianchetto the bishop
e6 97 knight
uh look at the charisma and then pray he
doesn't have a straightforward plan
yeah and a forcing uh play
and play play quickly gotta stay at the
head on the clock must be ahead on the
clock you cannot be worse on the clock
you will blunder under pressure why is
wesley so good in
uh these situations of rapid chess what
makes him
such a phenom when we play on the grand
chester he's a very practical player he
plays very fast he doesn't make mistakes
often and he keeps the position closed
he's a tactical genius as well let's get
that straight he's got a grade you make
a mistake and it's over and by the way
wesley just needs a drug that's it
that's it a draw is all he needs a win
would be nice by the way
if he were to do that if he were to make
he'd be the first repeat champion at
some time in years since i believe since
nakamura
or maybe godakomski oh
about eight or nine years yeah and by
the way he won it in 2017
as well yes
yes so 2017
2020 2020 2021 yeah he's a two-time
winner he's looking for his third
championship starts to add up those
numbers or was it 2018 where i think it
was 17. 2018 i believe was six
he won it the year after he won the
grand chess tour which was 2016. and
then he hit again fabie won in 2016.
wesley took it the next year when he was
winning everything then who won it in
2018.
that is true sam and then knocker won in
2019 then wesley won in 2020 and now
looking for 2021
title right now
destiny in his own hands we haven't had
a repeat win as we said the names of
repeat winners are legendary names like
nakamura like gotta come ski you got
your bobby fisher bobby fischer yeah so
did you win back-to-back championships i
don't think i did no that's how hard it
was
the problem was the price fund in my
days were so low
that i oftentimes didn't accept my
invitations because you know
there were three week
long events and they were held
not in the best of uh locations shall we
say and they competed with the
international tour as the players
are at the board
if we get started big moment if we
started today and said was he so beats
bobby with black we say it's over
tournament over we say the tournament's
over that's it was he so beats five we
blocked that's it he could not vote for
a better result and he should win and
that's what we're expecting right now
but that's why we play the games exactly
can a miracle of miracles happen right
now the underdog by a lot with his back
to the wall with the black pieces
on top of it pull this off i remember
annie wang and anaji pikitsi playing in
a playoff for the women's championship
that was amazing and how amazing was
that oh my goodness d4 on the board and
g6 we got it right you got it right we
got it right we said we thought you need
it exactly
and that first move
stopped wesley and he said okay how can
i force the draw in the most
easiest way g two g do you go for f5
for a leningrad
i don't wanna do that i don't want to do
that i really don't want to do that
against godly so you go back the problem
is
if i go knight f6 and that's the king's
indian i go g3 and in general i can keep
it close exactly exactly i think wesley
wants to play e4 or even
i think wesley wants to play a bishop g5
system
all right there you go he's moving his
opponent okay
now you've got to go into an old indian
as black whether you like it or not you
take on d4 and play knight f6 i like
this 97 idea if it's not losing
it's not the best place for the knight
but not sure h5 h4 h4 h4h5 would be the
recipe against this move that's the
problem h4 is uh and that's okay you're
going to give white the advantage
he didn't play for it he just can't as
wesley you're in a muscular situation
are you going to play h4 or castle
you're going to try to keep listen
you get a position the guy's crying in
front of you h4 and tell him you're
trying to win the game trying to make a
draw is a sure way to lose a chess game
that's not what you do but he doesn't
want to take any real chances i don't
think he's trying for a draw i think
he's just not going to play he's playing
for an advantage he's going to play for
advantage and keep the game close uh by
the way just a quick question for you
both
um are they draw offers
no i don't think so okay
since we don't we don't since there were
no draw offers clear answer to that but
in the actual challenge by the way this
is the championship there will be no
draw from this game
no i mean wesley is up a rook
and he says to the opponent you want to
draw
okay i'm a rook down uh no but i just
wanted to ask if if it was even
permitted that he was permitted we
haven't seen any draw offers this entire
tournament i remember days when people
argued i wrote an i wrote an article
called the end of the draw off
the end of the draw is what i called it
actually the end of the draw and people
blasted me for this article furious they
were angry what do you mean you can't
offer a draw anymore
what's wrong with you right
i was like i'm telling you it's better
for chess if you don't have draw it was
draw here we go f5 and f5 on the board
and now we've seen an entire tournament
played two sides exciting chess we've
seen it in the same field cup
it's easy the players just keep playing
it's not the worst the end of the world
f5 this is the chance he needed was
something sharp well if i'm in wesley's
shoes i'm taking i'm assuming
then i take on knight and h6 is hanging
so i have to take uh with the opponent
you do have to take with the pawn and
then i want to play eight uh c5
take the pawn
i thought e5 was hanging
so if you take on c5 i'll trade on d8
and i'll take and i'll take okay
i'm just trying to hoover you're trying
to make a draw yeah hoover things off
the board
right away be careful with those trying
to make draw situations again play the
best move he's done
and it and it happens to be the best
move it's not does it it's not trying to
make a draw it happens to be the best
move because black has created
weaknesses in his camp
that's the whole point he really has
yeah so you're taking advantage of the
weaknesses you don't have to do the math
to make a draw you just keep playing
great moves g3 e4 b4
same idea get in c5 i like that okay and
if a5 bishop a3 no bishop a3 i can't do
uh a5 b5
uh with the idea of bishop a3 remember
the blitz game between wesley soh and
gary kasparov where he went like b4 b5
c5 and gary came on set and he said
that was a that was a game of morphy
versus amateur
and i was the amateur said gary caspar
by the way this b4 move disposition has
been seen before before b4 before it was
a novelty really it
i i'm a bit surprised this is in the
database i thought still in that
database yeah but uh b4 strikes me as a
very logical move i just checked with
the engine it's giving a huge edge to
this novelty for white as we are ready
to play bishop to a3 c5 b5 and
everything is going to work this
diagonal is
is very uh
i want to say this bishop
is not doing anything here can't even go
there by the way bishop would not be
doing on anything on the e3 you look to
get your pieces as effective as possible
bishop a3 and again a statement moves
this is what we're saying you need to
make a draw your wesley soul you know
how you do it you make the guy beg for
it you know oh i need a draw no you will
beg for the draw keep playing aggressive
moves and see what i do to your position
he understands the circumstances and i
think that sam's f5
it looks like the most natural thing
like what else are you supposed to do
with the structure right but you do
create weaknesses instantly and you need
it to somehow let the game last instead
of just blasting your way through
because you need to make a win tonight
is happening the worst d4 right night
knight c6 it just feels a little bit
artificial not because i had e4
not that i had a good uh suggestion
for saying the board it does feel a
little artificial that you're putting
the knight here bishop a3 looks like a
very big tempo played i want to say
oh he played it very quickly three was
oh there's a rook f7 but i don't want to
put it on f7 well i'm thinking that
white's intent
is to capture this pawn and then capture
this knight and really wreck black
structure by the way keep in mind i just
don't want to see c5 when an immediate
c5 i think was played i don't want to
see c5 that's why i didn't want to put
the work on f7 and
bishop going to c4 what am i supposed to
do here by the way wesley is playing
super relaxed right now of course he is
he's just making moves
dominating putting pressure on his
opponent constant pressure this is this
is a man who knows that the championship
is his
if he does the right or the plucking uh
you he won with black already his
opponent is forced to win with the black
pieces and he can just keep the pressure
on
and roll
f
e4 is on the board f takes e4 not not
desirable but
again how do you react though after f
takes e4 i'm just taking on e4 or on d4
if you take on e4 i'm going to take on
f3 you're just taking it yes
i'm taking with the knight i'm going to
say go ahead yeah yeah yeah i got a lot
why can't you win material here there's
got to be something in
and take bishop c4 right now he's taken
he played it and he's played it it's
over this game is over
knight takes d4 you can't control
everything your position is going to
come out bishop c4
c4 is on the board if you take on c3 i'm
going to take on f7 then queen to d5
you're getting killed where do you put
the king getting destroyed
this is a this is a massacre right now
wesley's so dominating this playoffs
completely
as he's just going to
crush
both opponents well he stole the first
game basically but hey he got it points
got it now he's just gonna demolish his
opponent and say
i am the champ you gotta beat the champ
to take the title in boxing he's doing
it here in punishing style saying i am
the champ and that's it we've seen
material drop
and remember how disappointed wesley so
was after that draw in his interview
with maurice yes
i mean whatever he did to reset his mind
and get back into the competitive flow
he has
done it
he is dominating yes sir i'm sorry i i'd
love that to be the narrative but fabi
blew the last game he did bobby just
blew the game wesley will walk in here
and say i was lucky against bobby he
will not say that he just cruised he was
lucky against fabi fabi blew that game
and bobby probably has walked out of the
building right now seeing this position
on the board or maybe he's hanging
around because he knows congress he's
like are you kidding me i could have
done this whole thing it's gonna be in
here this could it could have been me
and look at this i think that
unfortunately for himself sam had to
drop material but i think he made the
best of it by getting a bishop
for the exchange and he's hoping that
he'll be able to get his queen to d5
and i don't know on a very very good day
be able to utilize the pawn so maybe
something like queen d5 knight here and
d3 at least you have the light squares
yeah at least
he's saying like if you can play that
pawn on d4 and not lose it in the next
few moves then you actually have a
chance okay you play for something
and he's targeting that pawn on d4
immediately
but also not only that he's he's making
sure that any
d4 d3 this bishop will not be offsides
sitting behind
this pawn on c5 also he's thinking that
should this pawn ever be tickled uh he's
got a defense sam has to play fast right
now because he's down on time two
minutes and 30 seconds he only has four
minutes and 30 seconds left on the board
i can't imagine him having a better move
than 25 25 i'm afraid of queen b3
against your queen d5 though
okay but at least i get a pawn bishop to
c4 bishop c4
okay as a prelude to queen d5 i'm not
sure i'm
i'm not sure i can support that move
that move well i mean i'm playing a4
if in that case queen with d5 i can play
knight d2
maybe hunt down this bishop
i'm not a fan of
but okay again uh the position is not
a4
whatsoever uh a4 of course queen d5 i
mean sam better start playing quickly
what's the time situation she only has
four minutes and a six trying 13 seconds
one
six minutes and
10 seconds left for wesleyan counting
this is uh
herculean task
we cannot overstate how difficult it's
gonna be for sam to come back in this
game he is in so much trouble right now
and he just gotta hope wesley makes a
horrible move
that's his only chance i think this was
a bad idea by sam i think knight d2 and
knight f3 which was plays itself for the
board
knight d2 and knight f3 i want to take
this one yes yes yes yes
you have to force that pawn from d4 to
move all the way to d3 allow me to
exchange dark square bishop and that's
all zero if i can do that if i can trade
the bishop then that's the game is over
right i'm thinking ab5 ab5 rook a1
bishop a1 maybe even queen a1 but okay
rook a1
bishop a1
and after bishop b5 knight
f3 this is my exact strategic
achievement that i want and make a point
about that position please because i
think the fans want to know why that's
so decisive
because you're going to have to be
forced to play d3
and expose your king
with
queen to
b3 and bishop takes g7 so
well i think it also actually
yeah you'll be in a lot of trouble with
your your pawns on that side as well
right exactly
exactly i'm just going to take on g7 go
quindi 2 take advantage of the weakness
of the dark squares in that position
let's make let's make a couple of moves
while we wait d3 continue with d3 bishop
he said bishop g7 yeah
and takes takes i think christian
mentioned queen b2 with a little nasty
threat of queen to b2 check
queen d2 or queen b3 which one do you
prefer queen d2 okay 22
sneakier
[Laughter]
i know christian has sneaky tactics
going for queen b2 rookie 6 of course is
a nice move as well
queen a watch lots of options
that's what he's been analyzing he's
going for that variation right now you
know i don't believe you can trade rooks
and get away and survive this he did
basically he's going to lose easily
rook takes a one so rook takes a1 now
here's the question though because queen
takes
a one was played okay because queen
takes a1 also had something and he's
playing right into our line he predicted
the game
the simple straightforward knight of
three and your position collapses quick
house of cards this is not going to hold
up knight f3 pushed upon trades as long
as white has a rook on the board your
pieces cannot fight back and that pawn
on d3 is just
not going anywhere not with the knight
on f3
and here we go
bishop takes g7 sometimes wesley makes
it look simple right win a1 that knight
is going to d4 and he's going to land on
e6 with devastating consequences ooh
i didn't even see that bishop d7 stops
stops you at least but
then i'm going to go queen to c3 or rook
to d1 focus on the d3 pawn and that's
going to be lost by the way i mean it's
already lost it's game over it's already
lost this game is death i mean wesley
had all he could dream of when he won
with the black pieces against fabi and
now four and then his opponent lost and
had to play for a win with black so
played very cagey chess very aggressive
chess i should say king back to g8 he
couldn't have gotten anything better no
he got everything he needed that was the
perfect result the perfect two results
when he was black there's 94 players he
played your move i thought rookie six i
was always thinking that the rook was
landing on e6 because of the g6 pawn
weakness but he played knight d4 i think
he wants to keep that rook on the first
rank just to be sure that no d2d1
somehow comes fast on the board queen c3
knight what do you do with this bishop
he's he's he's putting the question 96
is unstoppable mate the game is over 96
will be unstoppable so queen d5 for
example just loses to 96 right so you
you can't defend this piece you have to
move you have to play bishop to d5
that's going to allow me to pick up the
pawn on d3 your last threat in the
position and that's all she wrote guys
it's so bad right here right now
precisely
this is designable it is resentful it's
it's that bad one minute i don't see 10
seconds left for sam sevilla and by the
way this is a 50 000
game oh yeah he wins this game he takes
home the 50 000 prize sam will pocket 30
000 along with fabi as they tie for
second and third but this is a twenty
thousand dollar swing game
and whoa what is this this can not work
this is this is possibly work this is
what we call desperation it certainly is
that
um
knight to e6
knight c6 knight c6 is the one
everything finishes the game yeah no
knight c6 was the one i liked uh because
we're landing i also like on seven
actually b7 but knight c6 we're landing
on e7 with the rook
you guys are thrilling man like how many
we see we see victims
[Music]
ultimate moves you know hey coach put me
in
queen d7 allows rook to e7 that's good
uh where do you put the queen f8
but then b7
or takes on cc i mean
you name it this one is over wesley so
will be the champion
barring
a heart attack yes pretty much at this
point there's no way queen
where
g5 queen g5 but now i can just simply go
b7
b7 forcing you to take with the knight
because b8 is coming in i'm getting my
second queen and you lose the pawn
and he's and he's reaching for his bond
he's ready to go b7 d2
d2
oh look at that one checkmating threat
that's about it
my turn says
and that's it congratulations wesley the
champ wesley so
the repeat champ wesley
two in a row mandy might have argued
that 2020 was a pandemic year and they
played online and maybe just maybe
he didn't quite win a legitimate
championship of course it was but it was
online but he has done it once more
at the chess board in the world famous
st louis chess club and said yes indeed
i
reign as the best u.s player
period congratulations wesley really
really nice okay definitely a hiccup uh
in the game with fabby but
he played it at the very end incredibly
well he played a practical game he kept
his edge on the clock and he understood
how important that is in a 10 minute
game
with so much tension and remember we do
not see an increment in this format we
see the delay and we saw how fatal that
can be for a player that goes down to
their last few seconds that's happened
with abby
the delay i think it's a fine idea i
just like to see it played throughout
the whole tournament as opposed to
playing the entire tournament with an
increment and then only at the very end
and they're the lazy the sweet embrace
wesley's mom wesley he's the guy who he
plays fast whatever you do in front of
him right he's gonna play quickly and
quickly he's always practical he just
gets it done is they coming down
into the basement where we are
uh where the studio is but
the rightful champion 2021 u.s chess
champion wesley so but by the way uh i i
mean i just gotta say i i i think he he
played the best check he deserved it i
mean he was undefeated throughout
the classical portion and he is the
repeat champion
as he comes into the studio
he got a better handshake from maurice
than from any one of his opponents i was
like wow
you're practicing you're prepping you're
practicing for that yeah
okay
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
sharks like you in the water
first of all congratulations thank you
for winning the championship what does
it mean to win
also in back-to-back years that is not
something that's been done in quite some
time yeah it means a lot well first of
all i think the lord jesus oh glory to
him for
giving me the victory uh
i mean i got many people to think also
especially uh first i'd like to thank
our
big chess supporters without which none
of this would be possible uh rex engine
is sing filled they're right there
outside
i saw them watching the games genie
i think i've only seen genie three times
here in st louis but it's always nice to
have around very pleasant so
just a dedication that they give also
rex watching the games being here every
single day cheering out the players
i think it's none of the other
supporters ever
maybe maybe there are a few but
very rare to see but yeah winning this
tournament is a lot it's time to
celebrate uh i wasn't actually expecting
to be in a playoffs today i think
fabiano was pushing and pushing his game
yesterday
so
i was a bit disappointed if he won i
feel like i'm running out of energy also
in this tournament
but you saw him playing yesterday was
there a moment as you saw impressing
that you thought yeah it's over uh i've
got to let this one go
yeah that's true no we were my mom and i
were having dinner in the hotel
and we were following the games online
but of course the engines are very weak
so but it was giving like a winning
advantage for for fabiano after the
queen sack
uh so i thought fabiano was gonna push
it also sam was not playing his best in
this tournament so i thought it's over
it's done at that point but actually
later look at the game deeper and
fabiano was winning but it's a very
complicated win
so
and today anything can happen let me ask
you before we get to today the moment
you you found out that it was a drawing
it was clear to you that was a draw what
was your you're feeling like knowing
that the playoffs gave you a chance
today yeah very happy it's like giving
me new life uh i thought the tournament
was pretty much over by yesterday
uh fabian almost won three games in a
row well he won three games but not in a
row
so
it just gave me a new a new bread of
life that this tournament
might not be over that i might still
have some chances
and uh
yeah i'd like to thank sam for saving
that difficult game
and let's add to this one then today you
mean you've been sam shanklin yeah now
let's get to today
you play against fabi yeah and no bones
about it
he came at you and you are on your back
in this first game with the black pieces
yeah that's true well first of all i
think uh
i slept alright yesterday and i didn't
prepare anything i didn't look at any
chests i had a clear mind coming in i
just wanna play fast also the time
control it's two second delay not
increment so time is very crucial here
so i just want to play fast and make
some good moves
uh but the thing i thought i had a very
comfortable position out of the opening
when he got double pawn so i cannot
relax at that stage i knew he was going
to go all out fabby plays for a win with
both callers so i knew he was going to
go all out but somehow i misplayed the
position i i just
relaxed too early played some moves and
suddenly found myself in a very
difficult position uh and in the end
game
he probably missed a win somewhere
rook v1 instead of knight d5 was the the
moment as he
as he played uh against you would have
been much more
uh
challenging after he sacrificed
on c6 yeah this game is so weird like i
don't even know what we're moving i
think we are making tons of mistakes in
the middle game but
so i was no idea what's going on but on
ic6 yeah i think uh
yeah i think rook b1 is not easy to play
i guess king c7 knight b5 is the point
exactly
b6 i guess we both missed that i think
he had i mean at this point i think rp1
is not very clear because rook b1 kings
is seven
knight d5 king c6 rook b6 king d7 bishop
b5 king c8 and i don't see a win for
white so knight d5
king takes rook b6 king d7 bishop b5
king c8 but maybe the end game is
winning like you can i don't know
take on f6 or something
my rook is very awfully placed yeah your
rook looks uh
especially in hospitable huh maybe rook
to b7 right now
b7 king c6 rook f7 then just take on f7
oh you cannot take on d5 that's the
problem yeah this is very clean yeah so
after b7 maybe i should go to d6 but
yeah i'm pretty sure
it's lost like in d7 or b7
in d6 king d6 and maybe maybe take on f6
right now and then take on yeah but i
think the thing in this game i was
playing with no pressure like uh
i i didn't expect this play up so i was
just playing fast playing chess if
chances come good if i lose that's fine
too so
i'm absolutely just playing very calmly
yeah it paid off when did you feel
wesley that the tide had truly turned
well when i saw this when i put this
knight on d6 i feel like i'm holding
yeah like because my c pawn is very fast
yeah so
so when i brought my knight to d6 i feel
like i i feel i'm pretty sure he totally
missed this knight c8 knight d6 idea he
probably thought he was just winning
yeah i think e4 was bad move
because maybe he had some other tries
like rupee one but
yeah but when i got my knight to d6 i
feel like
the worst is over because such and also
later on like i wasn't thinking of
winning but
yeah here it's very unclear i thought
instead of king e3 i thought he had rook
b8 and rook g8
like f5
rb8 king c7 rook g8
looks much more
yeah but it's probably still it's
probably just a draw
yeah so
yeah better than the game yeah and i
think fabian i had no idea what was
going on and then
later in the game i looked at the club
and he had one second
right since this is uh
delay you don't gain any time so
and then next thing next thing i look
here he lost on time the arbiters
pointed out also right
then you obviously have to watch him
play against sam
and he managed to win that game which
was the best result for you because now
yeah now you knew that a draw was enough
assured of assured of even if i lose i i
we move on to the blitz right and yeah
so then the question became
how to approach a game that you know a
draw is enough how do you normally
approach that kind of situation or how
did you approach this one
well i
during the last few months i
prepared a repair tour for white with
1d4 when i only want to draw
so against all openings i played drawing
like i prepared drawing lines against
him so grandfather kings indian uh a
queen's gambit so
if i want to play safe i have a very
safe opening reporter with one d4 so it
helps a lot that i'm white ice black
anything can happen sam sebian is very
dangerous player also i saw his
interview yesterday and he said that
with black he tends to prepare solid
openings and stuff so that's very
comfortable with d4 i know he has to
play some dutch kings indian so when he
played what he played at some point it
seemed like you switched gears and said
i'm just going to be aggressive
particularly
at that point you were it looks like you
felt you had a great position and you
wanted to win
uh well i don't i didn't want to win i
just want to throw yeah
okay
the the worst thing happened is i relax
and then the position becomes slightly
more difficult well i know he could play
something like this knight d7
but i also knew that he's not very
experienced in such positions
and in planking's indian structures you
need tons of experience which
i think sam is not very familiar with
this knights here also knight d7 97
looks a bit dubious
and i think how i played with rook e1
bishop f1 is very solid
and i get queen side plays so i think i
didn't run
into any problems
in this game
again you're the champ
back to back championships does that
matter to you yeah it matters a lot
i think i remember 2017 i really wanted
to win my first uh championship because
it was
getting more and more difficult
and i wasn't sure if i was going to win
it but
now this is my third title and uh
and it's huge
i feel like the youth championship is
one of the tournaments that we have to
play every single year
and
winning the title is huge it's even more
important than the money
all right well congratulations you won
the title and the money you're the 2021
u.s champion yeah i'm afraid that today
in the tie bricks with two games and 10
seconds anything could happen i think
fabi should have won today considering
how well he played but
but yeah it's my today's my day
it was indeed wesley first of all
congratulations you came here in the
studio after your game against dania
nordisky dejected
how did you turn the tide at that point
[Laughter]
i just moved on and for and forgot about
it that was really painful
not because i would have moved the plus
three and also the rating and stuff
would be number six in the world and all
that
but
i
i i think it happens to everyone that's
that's the game of chess there's not one
player which have missed chances
uh in this tournament so i guess i look
at it like like a sportsman like in
basketball you can miss your shots or in
football you can miss your throws
i i think in chess that's just part of
the game that's why you just need to
keep getting better and improving and
improving and know that they're always
going to be instances which
you're going to miss
i mean yeah
it's hard but
you need to move on to the next game
the mindset of a champion absolutely
yeah
by the way
you are wrong on one thing
you said you thought plus three was
going to win the championship it turned
out plus two
wasn't enough yeah this is crazy yeah i
think uh
it's never happened before where place
to won a championship 2017 i was plus
three with uh with alexander nischuk and
i tied for first
but
i i think
yep this never happened before i think
uh linear fabi myself also shankel and
jeffrey so all 2700s were out of form in
this tournament as you can see but also
the championship is getting stronger
every single year like next year we'll
have levon so you can't really compare
2012 championships from this year yes
sir plus two winning the championship in
your memory i think once michael wilder
it was a very very very soft tournament
somehow nobody could could pull away but
it's very very rare wesley i just simply
wanted to say congratulations yeah uh
celebrate your victory it was very well
deserved yeah thank you so much jason
you guys totally unexpected
yeah maybe next year you
one of you can can can play again i mean
i look at her
i look at their games
if you want to take a break
actually wesley anytime you want we got
a hot seat right over here you wanna you
can play the car in english
we'll send uh
preparing for you right
yeah we're gonna send maurice first
give him a good
give him a good send off yeah i don't
know what opening more is please
and you won't
congratulations again thank you guys
and as uh wesley started his interview
with a thanks and a big shout out to
each and everybody as we get to see a
repeat
of how he won
the finishing touches we also want to
give a shout out to so many people
behind the scenes here at the st louis
chess club at scholastic center that
makes these broadcasts possible
start us off christian absolutely well
the guys and ladies at spectrum studios
of course randy kevin marcus brian baby
jan who takes care of us keeps us in our
play spectrum pardon me a silverback
video with kevin tom
kitay 80 years young
that's just so fun
sean nate will megan jim steffen and
evan var
or
of course are getting a participation
yeah of course
for the whole social media stuff leonard
the man behind the scenes make sure all
the dgt boards works and from the saint
louis chess class and the collection
these photos as well exactly that is
from the club jonathan ben
tracy danny eric
ryan rebecca emily thank you so
you guys are great and of course the big
bosses tony tony joy rex and eugenie
thank you juan and all really it's a
great pleasure it's so much fun
and let's review our standing starting
with the open absolutely well what a
championship this was and this is it
this is him the champion 2021 u.s chess
champion west cp after a dominant road
during the playoffs a repeat winner
congratulations to wesley and here's
everybody including their prices nicely
so 50 000
fabiano caruana and sam savion are going
to be sharing second position thirty
thousand dollars for both of those
gentlemen linear dominguez fifteen
thousand dollars ray robson fifty
thousand dollars alex lenderman fifteen
thousand dollars as well sam shanklin
nine thousand dollars
7500 john burke 7500 jeffrey shang and
daniel naradiski are sharing 10th
position 5 500 for both of those
gentlemen and lazaro bruzon with 4 000.
and our ladies champion christian well
we've crowned a champion yesterday in
that tournament that was the 2021 u.s
women's chess champion carissa yep very
very deserving and the whole list of
winners well we have carissa ip who
pocketed 25 thousand dollars golurk
begins
18 000
our congratulations to her in her debut
absolutely what a debut that was arena
crushed 13 000 dollars in third position
completing the podium katharina silva
tatev abrahamian and ashwita es warren
tied for fourth position
each of those ladies get eight thousand
dollars talia cervantes with five
thousand dollars
i was about to say nice to see tata
making a comeback at one moment she was
really languishing she really put
together come back sorry you were
mentioning
yes talia cervantes in seventh position
nazi pakis and anna zatonski tied for
eighth position
3750
each sabina foy shore ana sharovich and
megan lee are tied for 10th position and
yet take home 2500. our congratulations
to all the contestants for making these
uh championships so
memorable
maurice you always like to tell us the
u.s championships are your favorite
tournament
what do you think about these editions
these were fantastic no question about
it carissa's dominance after losing and
coming back winning five in a row that
bingo she put up against those fantastic
players something we've never seen a
woman winning against four former
champions that was terrific and these
playoffs
down to the wire what more could you
want as far as drama is concerned wesley
wesley so emerging as a rightful winner
this was a lot of fun it was a lot of
fun working with you two as well as the
first time this team has worked together
yes we've been working together for
years and years maybe decades yeah yeah
and always a pleasure my friend your
your attitude your spirit your
effervescence your way with words always
keeps us enthralled and entertained and
christian first time in the hot seat
leading the show
marvelous job
top of the line i didn't think you had
it in you when you first sat down
but man you rocked
without any question about it great work
and good to be with you guys for this
amazing hurrah last year of the year
enjoy the rest of the year guys enjoy
the holiday season such a pleasure to
work with you guys
and don't forget tonight we do have the
closing ceremony absolutely yes join us
we will be broadcasting that live from
the beautiful muni forest park lovely
we'll see you all there thank you for
sharing your day with us bye bye
everyone
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the st
louis chess club is prohibited